the jurogan experience let's talk about
the metaverse because like uh i'm really
fascinated by this decision of facebook
to change the name of facebook to meta
and to
the meta which i think people are just
gonna
they're gonna like re
they're gonna realize that
that this is this is a crazy idea that
you're gonna give your life to some sort
of augmented or virtual reality
world that's created by a guy
who's involved in this
company whose algorithms are sowing the
seeds of distrust and hate although but
now we're going to [ __ ] let him take
over
what you see and feel because you're
going to have a new company and this new
company is going to be virtually reality
based where he's literally he he
reenacted a scene from black mirror yeah
which is unironically i know and you
know what makes me a little sad i think
that it's gonna happen do you think it's
gonna happen yeah i think that you and i
are a different generation dude i think
there are a lot of kids who are growing
up in fortnite world and spend a lot and
i think the pandemic really accelerated
this there are a lot of people who lived
online for the entire pandemic and so
for people like me and for people like
my parents not seeing other humans for a
long time was actually quite painful and
terrible like we actually did want to
get out and be with the community and
see friends and do that sort of what if
you spend your entire life from the time
your little kid interacting with screens
what if those screens are getting
increasingly sophisticated so that they
are interacting with you in ways that
humans would what if you get to be
whatever like we're a society we're just
talking about this where you get to be
whatever you want to be what if there's
a world where you actually can be and
everybody sees you the way you want to
be seen would you rather live there
where you're like rich and good looking
and everybody likes you or would you
rather live in the real world where
you're disconnected from all that and
you end up with like ready player one
world i think it's going to happen
it's as long as it can become
indistinguishable from reality which it
will be able to be it's going to take
time whether it's five years or 10 years
if you go back and look at pong which is
the the first game that i ever saw when
i was a child it's ridiculous it's like
a white ball that bounces across and you
have a straight two battles that's a
paddle and it's the it's the dumbest
game you could never convince a child to
play today they'd be like get the [ __ ]
out of here with that stupid game i can
go play [ __ ] halo right but back then
when i was a child that was a big deal
if you extrapola if you go just go in
the future from now what they're
available what they have available now
with these insane video graphics the
unreal engine and then move yourself 20
years in the future yeah it's going to
be indistinguishable and the ai is
getting better and better in terms of
being able to imitate human behavior in
terms of being able to innovate on its
own and haptic feedback suits and all
these different things and all these
video games that they have that emulate
sports they're getting so close when you
watch these basketball games and the ufc
has a game when you watch these the the
players the fighters move around like
god it's so close it's not quite there
but they're getting better and better
with each iteration and it's just a
matter of time and what i wonder is if
we are
innovating ourselves when it comes to
this stuff if we're innovating ourselves
out of existence as a civilization but
don't you think that's probably where
this goes no matter what no i think i
think then the barbarians come to the
gate i think that's what happens really
because the real world still exists so
if you innovate an entire generation of
people
and
let's just take this on the most
baseline demographic level none of them
get married none of them have babies
in two generations this ain't gonna
matter you're gonna have a good time in
the virtual reality and then they're
gonna be no babies to carry this on and
the only on earth are going to be
religious jews religious catholics and
religious muslims and that's it
the vulnerability lies in the power grid
because the power grid is so vulnerable
that if someone just detonated the power
grid all this stuff stops and then you
have no life your life is completely
you've invested it completely in this
augmented world this virtual world but
this virtual world all you have to do is
pull the plug and it's out and it's out
for millions of people
it's like the equivalent of dropping a
nuclear bomb in a culture like if you
really all live inside of a computer
system some sort of uh
something art yeah that's virtual
reality yeah no that's right and it's
and what i fear is that when you do that
to a civilization it's basically the
equivalent of you bringing a wild animal
and you put it in a cage for a long time
and now you can't release it back in the
wild the right it's going to get eaten
what happens to you is a civilization
right what happens if you've taken an
entire generation of people told them
that their entire life exists online
they don't have to interact with other
humans they don't have to interact in
human ways with other humans and then
there's like an entire other earth out
there that isn't doing any of this right
by the way china's not doing this right
china is china's banning it yeah china's
banning it china's saying you're not
allowed to go online certain days of the
week if you're a kid right we're going
to ban the kind of stuff that you can
see
so in the long run which civilization is
going to be more durable the one that
actually understands the vulnerabilities
of human nature or the one that says
we're going to use those vulnerabilities
to make you feel subjectively happier
it's i think i'm amazed at the level of
conditioning like here's what killed me
about the pandemic honestly like well it
killed me the level of conditioning that
it took in order to rejigger how people
think was so low it shocked the hell out
of me it really shocked me i was talking
to my business partner jeremy boring
about this and early on in the pandemic
he was like people aren't going to stand
for this like when they shut everything
it's like three months from now people
are going to be losing their minds
they're going to be out on the streets
protesting to get rid of the masks and
they're going to be out at ball games
again i was like that's not right i
think it'll take a year we're like a
year and a half in and half the
country's still like oh you know what if
this just kind of continues like
all right i guess like the the amount of
dependency that was bred by people
saying just go back to your house and
people be like human beings are really
adaptable and this is something that
brett weinstein and heather hiring talk
about right that's our superpower we're
super duper adaptable yeah so
we're super adaptable to our own
detriment sometimes to our own detriment
so if we change our social circumstances
radically in a way that's unhealthy for
us and we are now interacting with
technologies that were built to take
advantage of our lizard brain yeah then
what happens when
there are people who are just not
engaging in the same they're not playing
the same game that we are right we're
we're essentially drugging ourselves
that robert nasek is the libertarian
philosopher he he talks at one point
about what he calls the experience
machine his thought experiment and the
experience machine is basically vr he's
writing this in early 1960s he says what
if there was a machine where you could
plug into it you'd feel the illusion of
choice you'd feel as though your choices
had some sort of significance and it
would give you the dopamine hit that you
get in regular life would you plug into
it or would you not right and his theory
was you wouldn't plug into it because
you still want to feel like your life
has real world consequences
but what if everybody is in everybody
you know is in that experience machine
then you're the one who gets left out if
you're not what is real world what is
the real world i mean that's that's what
the problem is that that analogy was
created before
the sophistication of computer systems
has reached the point now where you can
look at it 20 years from now and you
kind of get an understanding of where
it's going to be
when you when you're dealing with what's
possible now
i don't think you're going to be able to
stop people from doing it because i
think it's going to be so overwhelmingly
addictive you look at how many people
are just addicted to looking at their
instagram yep it's it's it's so simple
it's nothing i mean it's nothing the
dopamine hit you get off this little
phone stay it's minimal but people are
completely all in on it yep and i i
think that what that's going to what
i do wonder if there's going to be and i
wonder what you think about this if
there's going to be a bifurcation in the
same way there's been a bifurcation
about so many issues between the people
at the top of sort of the
elite spectrum and the rest of the
population where the people of the elite
spectrum are making the metaverse but
their kids aren't actually in the
metaverse right like steve jobs didn't
let his kid use an ipad exactly like
like i'm on the internet my kids are
seven five and one they're not allowed
we don't have the tv on in our house my
kids don't watch tv
i'm not my kids don't get internet
access until they're like 18 like that
is not a thing i want 18.
they can be out of my house and they can
get in there they're going to do drugs
they're going to be in the street
your kids are going to turn tricks well
it's going to be a real problem
it's going to be a problem that's a
pretty wild ride you took me on there
joe that's that's that's really
upsetting that's what i do oh yeah yeah
that was we went straight for my kids
aren't watching coco melon to they're
turning tricks in the streets
it's it's such a
it sounds so cute
for what it actually is yeah you know
it's a terrible thing but it sounds like
cute oh they're turning tricks like you
didn't understand english like oh
they're the magicians
and they're like no no of a sword
yeah but yeah i mean we're gonna limit
but i think that that's one of the
stories if we're talking about the elite
kind of versus everybody else gap maybe
everything that gets everything that's
concerned about their children
with everything right yeah i mean like
people promulgating technologies and
value systems they don't actually live
in right and then everybody who is
watching is like i will do that right
and then those people themselves don't
do it watch the entire episode for free
only on spotify